it's a scene which is shocked even those
hardened to witnessing the aftermath of
motorway accidents and from the tangled
mass of wreckage police investigators
must try to piece together evidence of
how it happened sadly I can now confirm
that we believe we've had at least seven
people died as a result of this incident
we fear that that number will rise as
the day continues and we carry out an
extensive search of vehicles and a
carriageway at the scene those who were
there moments after some of the vehicles
burst into flames risked their own lives
trying in vain to save others who were
trapped once the fires took hold there
was no way they could be rescued some
cars were stuck beneath trucks motorists
who survived talked of the thump-thump
fun as more vehicles joined the pylon
all such accident investigations will
look at factors such as weather
conditions and the speed of the traffic
it was dark wet and there was fog in the
area though some witnesses say it may
have lifted soon after the crash but the
date meant there were fireworks displays
in the area including one at a rugby
club adjacent to the motorway it's not
clear whether a motorist may have been
momentarily distracted or whether the
display had ended the father display was
obviously still going on when this glow
was happening than to lesson from my
house the accident is the left of where
the pilots play was so it could well you
know obviously someone may well have
been having a look look it was a pretty
big display I think and maybe that yeah
it could be parking out of that the
police in the Far guys were under a lot
of pressure and it was the flames you
know I mean I've never seen a fire like
that myself and you could see you know
as we were coming towards that the
flames are going up and it did seem like
the things you know either exploding all
things are setting a light and adding to
that heat the motorway will remain
closed all day as well as the police
inquiry the northbound carriageway is
still completely blocked and damage to
the road surface and the central
reservation will have to be repaired and
the accident is bound to renew the
debates over Britain's motorway speed
limit the government is considering
raising it to 80 miles per hour safety
campaigners who want to know whether
speed contributed to this carnage Ian
woods Sky News Taunton